hi hi honey how are you doing I don't
know I'm assuming you saw all of the
backlash on the variety interview yeah I
just wanted to see where your head's out
right now I'm like mortified yeah
remember when Kim Kardashian had the
internet all worked up over sharing her
secret to success during an interview
with variety I have the best advice for
women in business get your ass up and
work well now fans are getting a behind
the scenes look at that moment and the
backlash that followed on the Family's
Hulu series The Kardashians I mean maybe
I should make a statement and like
clarify what I meant before it gets
worse okay well let's sleep on it and
decide if you want to respond I love
that the episodes are more a little bit
documentary style and I think that you
have a real insight into what the girls
are doing not only you know what you see
in the press or whatever but what's
really happening behind the scenes let's
rewind back in March the kkw beauty
founder joined her sister's Courtney and
Chloe along with their mom Kris Jenner
for a candid chat with variety it seems
like nobody wants to work these days so
true some people weren't feeling Kim's
words of wisdom pointing out that the
skims founder grew up in Beverly Hills
with a lot of privilege we have
different views sometimes well on the
latest episode of the famous family's
reality series Kim admits the public
uproar surprised her like I said what I
said about people working do I believe
in that yes I believe that you have to
work hard in order to do that but I was
just so blindsided by how angry people
got and when Kim contemplated how to
handle the controversy her mom told her
to take a beat I don't know what to do
because I obviously
it's all my fault because you know it's
not your fault sweetie
it's understood where you were coming
from I mean maybe I should make a
statement and like clarify what I meant
before it gets worse okay well let's
sleep on it and decide if you want to
respond Kim eventually addressed the
Critics on Good Morning America saying
that the now Infamous sound bite was
taken out of context a question right
before was after 20 years of being in
the business you're famous for being
famous
I my whole tone and attitude changed
with the previous question that went
into that question about
what advice would you give to women but
following Kim's GMA appearance variety's
Chief correspondent Elizabeth wagmeister
who did the interview with the
Kardashians shot down Kim's claims
tweeting that the question about being
famous for being famous actually came
after she was asked to give her best
business advice which is exactly how the
interview played out on the Kardashians
get your ass up and work success is
never easy so you just if you put in the
work you will see results
that brings up a good point because I'm
sure you are all so sick of hearing this
but you still see commentary which I
think is ridiculous when people say the
Kardashians they're famous for being
famous and now Kim says her message was
Lost in Translation when I made that
statement it wasn't a blanket statement
towards all women like as if I didn't
think women work hard or respect the
work that they do because
I see it every single day I hated that
that got
misunderstood and for that I'm so sorry
while some people may not be here for
Kim's business advice get your ass up
and work back in 2018 she told ET you
just gotta go for it I think my smartest
business decision has been
going for it
and not being like having no fear and
just even if they failed and even if it
hasn't turned out the way that I wanted
to I've learned so much from it so my
advice would be
go for it
[Music]